Gabriela wrote in if your family or
friends heard that you had been arrested
David but weren't told why
what would they assume you had done well
interestingly enough I have been
arrested I told the story on the program
before four months shy or six a six
month shy of my 21st birthday I was at a
party holding a beer that I had not yet
even had a sip of a friend of mine when
there was a knock at the door stupidly
said come in which allowed police
officers to enter I happened to be right
in front of them holding this beer and I
did end up being arrested although I was
never charged and yeah I mean it was one
of the dumbest things they ended up
closing the party down and sending
people home with drunk drivers in order
to bring me downtown
oh no parties everybody's got to leave
who can drive people home and drunk
people volunteered to drive people home
which they okayed because they needed to
take me downtown sometimes they'll bust
the party tell everyone to go home and
then pull them all over and arrest them
for drunk driving yeah that's true they
didn't do that here in any case I think
at this point like if I said to you Pat
if you heard through the grapevine
David's not gonna make it in today
because he's been arrested
what would you assume I had been
arrested for well probably not underage
drinking at this point at this point um
probably some financial crash yeah Myra
money-laundering or doing something
sketchy I mean III think people I don't
think people would assume if they know
me that I was money laundering but I
think people would assume tax evasions
something related to even an innocent
mishap but that like something
calamitous took place with like the
taxes of the of the show or that there
was some I don't even know some
something financial that that happened
and whether people think I'm a good
person or not a moral person would
probably influence whether they would
assume it was an innocent mistake that
I've been pulled in for or that I was
like hiding some kind of horrible
financial like Madoff thing that I was
doing or something like that
but I think most people in my life would
assume that it was like something very
very white-collar yeah probably a
financial crime or something along those
lines yeah so for me I think it would be
assault and battery or Breaking and
Entering or armed robbery of some kind
and this was what people assumed about
me I would assume a
Alton battery only because some of the
stories you've told we're something
relatively minor seems to really like
inflame your anger like when will you
almost fought a guy on on a recent trip
because he was like asking for money or
something like that remember though
there was that one yeah yeah I was
walking my bicycle yeah down the street
here because I had to cross some busy
intersection I didn't want to ride
across all right some guy decided to ask
me about the bike and I don't know what
this guy was talking to me about but I
just wasn't feeling it at the time yeah
and so he started to like push me into
like the fence as he was walking next to
me because he thought I was
disrespecting him huh and so to respond
I just like kept elbowing me elbowing
him as I walked along the path Wow and
it was like this whole physical
confrontation eventually he backed down
though that's good
so I mean I wasn't arrested at that
point but don't happen again I do think
that if I heard you were I would assume
you got into a fight oh and also you you
know you you're in instill in these sort
of like warts Barbro complex that's very
common in boston and a lot of times just
by one's presence in that scene you
don't even really have to do anything
wrong someone who's been drinking thirty
bush lights will get very angry for no
reason and you might end up in an
altercation
yeah and that I think is also something
that that you could get wrapped up into
plus I still have that young male
misconception of invincibility right no
question about that goes okay I think
eventually it doesn't you know more
years yeah
all right so financial crimes for me I
would say grab Gabriela and being
involved in some kind of fight I think
would be most most common for Pat maybe
throwing a bicycle at someone alright
get your questions in we will answer
three more next week but that's not it
for today we still have the bonus show
next which you can access by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show what
a day